Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So now the Buddha had made this amazing breakthrough and he'd wondered whether people would be able to understand what he'd discovered and overcoming his doubt
he sought his five companions so these are the ascetics that he'd been with for a few years practicing austerity all that sort of stuff and remember when he approached them they they didn't really want to see him you know he's done soft so they said and when he started talking to them it doesn't come up actually in the discourse on the turning of the wheel of the law
that's more formalized but in the Vinaya which is the rule of the monks where it describes things a bit more he says that as he's giving that talk he's constantly asking them have you ever heard me speak like this before?
have you ever heard me say these things before?
and by the end of that first discussion that he'd had in which he laid down the platform of his understanding the Four Noble Truths
that there is suffering unsatisfactoriness which is pretty straightforward pretty obvious that the cause of it is this of the obvious psychological cause is this desire which translates as seeking happiness in the sensual world seeking happiness in this phenomenal world that's a big problem and the third noble truth which says that there is an end to suffering and it is when this particular sort of desire
He's completely eradicated.
And then, of course, he goes on to the path, right understanding, right attitude, right intention.
And there's right speech, right action, right livelihood.
So you've got to bring it right into daily life.
And then there's the meditation, right effort, right mindfulness and right concentration.
So now after he'd spoken, presumably in the morning, it was said that they all went off to get some food.
They all went off on alms rounds.
And having come back and had a little lunch to revive their spirits and had a little kip, as you do, they got together again and the Buddha is said to have delivered this particular sermon on the characteristic of non-self, the Anattalakana Sutta.
So what I'll do first is just read it straight through so that you get the gist of it.
It's not very long, of course.
And then we'll go back and have a look at what he's saying.
So thus have I heard.
Before I start, Bhikkhu Bodhi's translations, this is the book in the Buddha's words, is literal and sometimes a little difficult in style, but he's trying to be as close to the text as possible.
And as we go through the text, then you'll see there are other ways of expressing things.
So, thus have I heard, on one occasion the Blessed One was dwelling at Baranasi, which is Benares,
present day Benares, in the deer park at Isipatana.
Now there the Blessed One addressed the monks of the group of five.
Thus, monks, venerable sir, those monks replied, and the Blessed One said this, monks form is non-self.
For if monks form were self, this form would not lead to affliction.
And it would be possible to determine form.
Let my form be thus,
let my form not be thus but because form is not self form leads to affliction and it is not possible to determine form let my form be thus let my form not be thus feeling is not self perception is not self non-self volitional formations are non-self and consciousness is non-self now for those of you who know the five khandhas
and who have been diligently attending these talks will remember that this is the way the Buddha looks at our experience through these five heaps.
And for each of them, and we'll just repeat the one about consciousness, he says the same thing.
For if monks' consciousness were self, this consciousness would not lead to affliction,
and it would be possible to determine consciousness let my consciousness be thus let my consciousness not be thus but because consciousness is non-self consciousness leads to affliction and it is not possible to determine consciousness let my consciousness be thus let my consciousness not be thus now what do you think monks is form permanent or impermanent impermanent venerable sir is what is impermanent
suffering or happiness suffering venerable sir is what is impermanent suffering and subject to change fit to be regarded thus this is mine this I am this is myself no venerable sir is feeling permanent or impermanent is perception permanent or impermanent are volitional formations permanent or impermanent is consciousness permanent
impermanent impermanent venerable sir is what is impermanent suffering or happiness suffering venerable sir is what is impermanent suffering and subject to change fit to be regarded thus this is mine this I am this is myself no venerable sir therefore monks any kind of form whatsoever whether past future or present
internal or external, gross or subtle, inferior or superior, far or near, all form should be seen as it really is with correct wisdom thus, this is not mine, this I am not, this is not myself.
Any kind of feeling whatsoever, any kind of perception whatsoever, any kind of volitional formations, any kind of consciousness whatsoever
whether past, future or present, internal or external, gross or subtle, inferior or superior, far or near, all consciousness should be seen as it really is with correct wisdom thus, this is not mine, this I am not, this is not myself.
Seeing thus, monks, the instructed noble disciple becomes disenchanted with forms,
Disenchanted with feeling.
Disenchanted with perception.
Disenchanted with volitional formations.
Disenchanted with consciousness.
And becoming disenchanted, he becomes dispassionate.
Through dispassion, his mind is liberated.
And when it is liberated, there comes the knowledge.
It's liberated.
He understands.
Destroyed his birth.
The spiritual life has been lived.
What had to be done has been done, and there is no more coming back to any state of being.
That is what the Blessed One said.
Elated, those monks delighted in the Blessed One's statement.
And while this discourse was being spoken, the minds of those monks of the group of five were liberated from the taints of non-clinging.
There we are, you see.
Anybody liberated?
you see it's the way you say it it's the way he said it I reckon I don't have it you see now liberated from the taint by non-clinging excuse me by non-clinging now
As I say, some of the words he uses are debatable, but we can first of all begin by taking from this discourse what exactly was understood at the time by a self.
So we're going back now to the Brahminical tradition, which predates what we call Hinduism.
Remember at that time there was also a great change in their way of thinking.
The Vedanta was being completed.
The Upanishads were just being written, well, made up, created.
And they were coming out of the ritualistic way of living through the Rig Veda, coming to understand that.
ritual that ritual didn't actually bring results and this great movement at that time of people going into the forests and and living the aesthetic life was all part of this loss of confidence existential problem and remember you've got to put that in context of the whole axial age because the same thing similar things happening in China with Lao Tzu in Greece with Socrates and Moses
so and probably all over another part of the world that we don't know of so the whole of human consciousness was moving you see and really the big message of the age you know was do unto others as you would have them do unto you not do unto others before they do unto you so now what what was understood by a self at that time okay
the self was the center of power of itself so the whole idea of a self was that you were in complete control that's the first thing we'll come back to it the second thing was that it was permanent it wasn't changing it was always the same and the third one was that it was happy it was always happy now if you think about it
if you have complete power over your being then you could say to yourself from now on I'm going to be happy and that'd be it that'd be the end of it, wouldn't it?
you would be happy all the time and that would presume a state of continuity a state of absolute continuity so this was the idea of a soul, an atta as understood at that time so we have to remember that, yeah?
I presume that you get a similar explanation of spirit or soul in other religious traditions and what he's doing now he is not saying and this is a really important point nowhere in the scriptures do you see him saying there is no self there's never a metaphysical statement he never goes that far it's a teaching tool he's asking if
if the self is the center of power and has complete power over what it thinks it is and if it is permanent and if it is always happy then where is it?
so now he's asking us the first thing is form is non-self now this word form remember is referring to the body
In a more subtle sense, it's more to do with the experience of the body at its sense base.
And there we go into those four great elements, the Mahabhuta, which we've also done, and which of course you'll all remember.
Fire, earth, water and air, which refer to the properties of temperature, the property of pressure or lack of it, the property of
movement and the property of cohesion or elasticity and it is understood that you can reduce all sensations down to some combination of these even sight which would be more the fired element and we know that the ear for instance is basically a pressure point there's no sound as such there's no sound in the universe there are simply waves waves of pressure and in your meditation you can get down to that
When it comes to the more difficult senses like tasting and smelling, even so, these are said to be combinations of these four.
So now, we'll just do this one, and we'll sort of draw it to the end there.
So what he's saying is, is this body, right, is this body a self?
If it were a self,
then it wouldn't lead to affliction.
It wouldn't lead to suffering or unsatisfactoriness.
So the question is, are you in a state of continual satisfaction with your body?
No.
He says, right, well it can't be that.
He says, is it possible to say then to this body, from now on, you will remain at the age of 30, and you will not move, or whatever age you felt to be at your most, you know, your most greatest physical prowess.
And then he's saying, if not, if you can't say that, and you can't say let it be this, let it not be that, then it must be a not, it can't be a self.
You know, it must be, it cannot be something over which you can say you have power.
Right?
So that's what he's saying.
So he's asking us to always recognize that the body
although we have superficial control over it fundamentally we have very little control over it if it falls seriously ill, when it falls ill, it just falls ill we don't even know what's happening in the body I mean, have you any idea now what your liver is doing?
you might know intellectually, you might have read about it but actually, can you now know what your liver is doing?
Are you aware that red blood corpuscles are moving out of the marrow of your bone and into your bloodstream?
See, it's a completely weird state we're in.
So, this is the first argument that he puts to us.
That if we think, if we ask ourselves, who am I?
Or what am I?
One way to look at it is, am I in control of it?
Is it completely within my power?
That's all.
And then next week we'll revise that by going through the others.
And a bit more to be said about that too.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
May, through your careful investigation of the quality of power over your body,
lead you to liberation from suffering sooner rather than later.